I was a child at the 80s I grew up
loving those classics Spielberg and
coming-of-age tales and that was
something that I wanted to bring to the
humble-bee we get to go back in time
with bumblebee and see where he came
from and see him in his original form
Travis is taking the story back to the
beginning set in the time period where I
first fell in love with transformers
to take this big expansive franchise and
to focus in on a corner of that canvas
we really get to understand who
bumblebee is and why people love it this
is why you're here be
[Music]
let me tell you something
a driver on picnic are
car pick to drive some mystical bond
between man and machines of mystical
bomb
between man
[Music]
[Applause]
you got people out they will need you
this is why you're here be
I know be music can help you say what
you're feeling try this everybody as
Charlie Comic Con is coming up we got
another Transformers preview they're
doing a panel so they'll probably
release more footage with Starscream
because even though we all saw him in
the last big trailer he looks like
classic 80s Gen 1 Starscream they
haven't officially said who he is or
who's going to be voicing him during the
movie there were a couple new
Decepticons that they've revealed
recently too and the voice actors that
were playing them so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Comic Con
videos it is gonna be crazy next week in
speaking of Hailee Steinfeld obviously
the start of the Transformers film not
including bumblebee really it's the
Transformers that are the stars of this
franchise everybody's known that for a
long time but she's the character that
they're using to ground the film in the
real world like this film is the ant-man
and the wasp of the transformers
universe the war has begun and one
question remains
like you have this big string of
michaelbay 150 million dollar-plus films
people starting to get a little fatigued
so they want to try something a little
bit different they go smaller instead of
going bigger so I do believe the rumor
that if this film does well it will
serve as sort of a soft reboot
jumping-off point for the rest of the
Transformers films going forward so what
you would expect out of this though like
even though Optimus Prime is supposed to
be featured somewhere in the film he's
not the biggest character it's really
bumblebee and Starscream probably the
two biggest characters meaning they
might also reference Megatron but I'm
not expecting to see him they really are
going back to the board with this film
like forget about all the crazy King
Arthur and the knights of the round
table that you saw during the last big
film I think they're just forgetting
about that prehistory and sweeping it
under the rug which i think is totally
fine I think they're trying to get back
to that Steven Spielberg boy in his car
albeit with Hailee Steinfeld that
Spielberg wanted to do for that first
Transformers film when he was still
going to direct it I'm gonna tell you
something son a driver don't pick the
cause mm cause the driver it's a
mystical bond between man and machine
remember when he announced it a long
time ago but then Michael Bay came on
and he sort of took over the franchise
so he had this sort of et vibe mixed
with a Michael Bay directed film like
obviously he directed the film so no
matter how much input Steven Spielberg
gives him it's still gonna look like a
Michael Bay film but by the time we get
to the second film Steven Spielberg was
really just an executive producer in a
financial sense like he earned a
percentage of all the Transformers
movies but he wasn't really involved
with the franchise creatively so it
stopped being that really classic
Spielberg Ian type of movie and being
totally Michael Bay which regardless of
how this movie turns out I will give it
bonus points for for just pivoting away
from all that madness I think the more
apt comparison for this bumblebee movie
is they're going for a more Iron Giant
vibe which is totally awesome still one
of my favorite superhero films
especially for the fact that it
references superhero films within that
film
[Music]
speaking of which Hailee Steinfeld in
you know transformers you could kind of
consider it a superhero sub-genre
she's also playing spider-gwen in
spider-man into the spider verse for
Sony they're doing a panel there'll be a
new trailer for that too where we'll
probably get some more dialogue for her
hey guys
okay who are you i'm gwen stacy so if
you're a big fan of Hailee Steinfeld
there'll be a whole bunch of her all
over a Comic Con next week but the brand
new Decepticons that they announced our
big characters during the film are
called shatter and drop kick shattered
turns into a red Plymouth Satellite
voiced by Angela Bassett very
recognizable voice you'll probably
detect her right away and then dropkick
turns into a blue AMC Javelin in his
voice by justin theroux who also has a
fairly recognizable voice so this is
what their car designs will look like
they might be like a subtle variant on
it because the movies taking place
during the 80s but most of these cars
came out of the 70s so they are pivoting
away from like the crazy supercars that
Michael Bay would put in his home like
no more Bugattis this film is taking
place in a coastal town in the 80s that
doesn't look like it's super rich so the
cars that the Transformers and the
Decepticons turn into reflect that I'm
guessing that also means that if Optimus
Prime physically appears during the
movie he's gonna turn into the classic
Freightliner flat-6 over-the-top truck
that he turned into during Gen 1 pretty
much everybody turning into the Gen 1
versions of their characters which I
know there's been a lot of discussion
about the type of jet that Starscream is
transforming into because originally he
was an f15 Eagle he was an f-14 tomcat
at one point he was a Russian fighter
jet then during Transformers Prime he
was an f-16 eagle based on the forked
tail there I'm guessing that they're
going for f-16 eagle but you guys can
let me know in the comments which
version of the jet do you think that
he's turning into so what will happen is
is there'll be a scheduled video that
I'll post early next week because there
will be a lot of stuff dropping there's
gonna be a bumblebee panel on Friday
night they'll definitely drop some more
footage
I'm guessing mostly to highlight the
Decepticons and the Starscream character
like pretty much most of the characters
that they haven't put in
the previous trailers I would be
surprised that they stuck Optimus Prime
on that but because they're trying to go
big I wouldn't be surprised if there was
a whole bunch more John Cena in it too
while you wait for everything click here
to watch Tom Holland give away some of
the plot of Avengers 4 and click here
for new venom from comic-con thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]